dylan sprouse has no right to look that
damn cute i can't
come here little mama
hello my name is dylan sprouse i play
jake in my fake boyfriend but today
i'm going to be reading some of your
thirstiest tweets
[Music]
remember when i was going to be the
future mrs dylan sprouse
no
i've never even met you
how could you be my wife numero does
dylan sprouse is so pretty i'll throw up
right now
if you're watching this
feel free to vomit dylan sprouse is so
hot
thank you
dylan sprouse please whisper in my ear
come here little mama
i have to know if dylan sprouse smells
good or like ace spray actually
this is a little tmi most people regard
me as a stinky who dylan sprouse is such
a geek i'm in love
thank you
i'm a little bit of a geek yes and i'm
proud of it dylan sprouse has no right
to look that damn cute i can't
you're right
i have no right to but
here we are again
looking this damn cute
dylan sprouts and daddy is a genderfluid
dreamboat
and then they did correct it to sprouse
so
i appreciate that i liked that project
quite a bit
and i'm glad that you did too
that's it
that's the thirstiness for today and now
i'm actually thirsty thank you buzzfeed
and you can watch
this movie my fake boyfriend now
[Music]